alla s'est effectivement lundi avec
cette jeune femme qui est venu sur notre
plateau claire nouvian qui la liste
place publique
effectivement on fait une émission ce
que des c'est un peu notre émission
c'est vrai qu'il ya parfois des échanges
assure un peu virulent mais j'ai envie
de dire que on termine l'émission elle a
été houleuse je trouve que l'émission
n'a pas été formidable mais il ya assez
peu de tweed donc on termine l'émission
elle reste jusqu'au bout on se dit au
revoir tout va bien et sait et elle nous
dit à la fin je reviendrai à tout ça
vous dit je reviendrai tous à clément
est vraiment y'a pas de moi j'ai pas de
problème personnel avec a bien sûr mais
24 heures plus tard ouais un montage
harry sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
intéressant pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant que vous le montrions aussi
comme ça parce que ce montage lorsqu'on
le voit de cette manière là on peut
comprendre c'est pas on peut comprendre
pour le coup c'est l'admets mais la
vérité c'est que ça c'est absolument pas
passé comme ça passait comme ça et c'est
ça qu'il faut les réactions lorsque moi
je commence les missions en me moquant
d'une certaine manière
effectivement et dire attention le
réchauffement climatique
il a fait -3 ce matin qui peut
considérer que je suis climato
sceptiques en disant cela
oui je je m'amuse où je caricature celui
qui le matin d'hier et nos réchauffement
de maladie qui fait -3 degrés mais ç'a
pris une telle folie une telle ampleur
sur les réseaux sociaux que je vais vous
citer il ya eu des tonnes de twitter
mais je vous citez un tweet un seul
celui de martine aubry c'est pas
n'importe qui marque maire de lille
maire de lille elle dit ce matin sur ses
news
pascal praud s'est lancé dans une
diatribe négationniste diatribe
négationnistes sur le réchauffement
climatique
faux expliqué madame aubry que le mot un
négationniste un mot qui datent de 87
quai uniquement attaché au génocide et
principalement à la shoah
donc elle parle de négationnisme et elle
a insulté de mad et il a insulté de
manière honteuse et misogyne sont
invités claire nouvian qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous disais que je
réponde à ça alors on a on a une compil
des extraits du clash alors ouais là on
a le clash
voilà on va voir alors il ya plein de
gens voilà qui ont réagi sur twitter on
va voir alors vous vous pensez que
comprenez la polémique de ce côté vous
vous ne la comprenait pas vous allez
nous dire pourquoi regardez il est là le
réchauffement climatique
attention sujet sensible on ne rigole
pas avec le réchauffement climatique
merci d'être avec nous le réchauffement
climatique faut pas oublier que ça
serait juste un mot quand même sur cette
histoire de réchauffement climatique
parce qu'alors il fait moins 3 degrés
dans paris donc quoi ça m'amuse et oui
il fait pas bon avait une fête qui
débute qui vous êtes entraîneur vous
avez réussi à entrer sur de l'humain
face à face à villefranche ou alors
parce qu'ils ne sont plus disponibles
je pense que les bots exprès les beaux
extraits sont évidents sur le site de
seignosse landes où tous les genres
alors ils peuvent qui veulent voir les
mesures par exemple
c'est vrai que la première personne et
c'est pour ça que j'interviens qui dit
quelque chose c'est pape n'aurions qui
dit ah ouais vous êtes d'un mois
j'interviens quand elle dit vous êtes
dingues et effectivement elisabeth lévy
à tort d'ailleurs parce qu'elle lui dit
mais vous vous êtes folle donc moi j'ai
un terrien et jeudi sa première fois que
vous venez sur ce plateau
calmons nous et c'était 1 mais comment
dire ces teintes le climat pour le coup
n'était pas bon dans un émission alors
donc c'est effectivement ce qui comprend
la polémique dit me mohamed dit-on
pourquoi oui ça me fait un peu mal que
mal au coeur parce que j'aime bien votre
émission et ça fait penser à l'époque
moi j'étais aux grandes gueules sur rmc
si finalement même chose on y va pour la
casc la casse tête et ça donc quand on
va dans chez vous on sait très bien que
ça va crier ça va gueuler que c'est le
principe c'est le principe de l'énergie
nous à sucre ça chez réseaux sociaux
donnent une image à travers des buzz
mais il n'y a pas des buzz tous les
jours hier on avait fait une émission
sur la biodiversité à mes mails un beau
grand et lourd j'aimerais quoi sur sa
dites nous pourquoi alors vous le placez
de l'émission quand même c'est d'aller
créer le débat et la plena sur quoi je
parle quand on cherche trop la polémique
on peut créer un mauvais buzz et là on a
l'impression que c'était un guet-apens
certes le montage est scandaleux le
répète de omettre les premières insultes
fait que ma désormais on a l'impression
que vous êtes c'est ce qu'on a fait nous
aussi donc on a fait aussi du mauvais
pas
sergine voilà je trouve je peux pas vous
soyez là sexistes fait ça j'ai une
famille néanmoins je pense que parfois
vous avez peut-être manqué de sang-froid
et lorsque vous dites à cette femme
qu'elle est hystérique je pense qu'assez
mois à vous ne dites pas ça alors si
vous voulez que je dise la phrase
exactement je vous la cité la phrase
alors vous donner une image hystérique
de votre pensée oui mais c'est pas à moi
de le dire ça c'est éric single bodies
et été galvanisés et du coup on a
vraiment l'impression qu'elle a chargé
que la nano comme souvent le plateau
bascule toujours la même façon et en
entrée en matière lorsque vous dites oh
il fait moins 3 degrés à paris le
réchauffement climatique moi j'assure
qu'en tant que téléspectateur je n'ai
pas compris l'ironie à l'ordre social un
manège pas la finesse d'opinion pour
comprendre ça mais j'avais l'impression
d'avoir en face de moi les mêmes
personnes qui cherchent à comparer mon
titre de docteur en médecine alors
recherche sur google et lorsque vous
dites à cette femme qui a 25 ans de
métier
vous allez vous dire la tri s'est fait
comme 25 ans rail dans le climat vous
dites hausse était de 25 ans vous
trompez je pense que vous avez là
j'aurais pas dû nadir et à d'accord on a
l'impression que finalement tout le
plateau et c'était contre l esaa
elisabeth lévy dans un ton franchement
voilà donc situer et du court 10 à elle
est seule face à tout le monde
or on sait très bien que après montage
c'est facile de faire parler les images
et c'est là où c'est scandaleux parce
que l'émission est en direct un jeu le
rappelle donc c'est un montage qui a été
fait ensuite sur les réseaux sociaux
isabelle est entièrement d'affaires veut
ce qu'il vient de dire moi même tu m'as
convaincu c'est jimmy à dire que johnny
pardon ça veut dire que tu m'as
convaincu parce que effectivement moi
j'avais vu tous ces montages des bribes
simplement en revanche effectivement
elle était seul contre tous
voilà c'est ça vraiment pu imaginer
c'est le cas par exemple cyril où vous
jouez le rôle de modérateur pour pas que
la même personne pour finalement se
soient noyés et vous j'ai l'impression
que vous étiez du côté de vos
chroniqueurs parce que peut-être vous
partager la même opinion et je me suis
dit mais c'est plus son rôle de
chroniqueur
ce qui est fou c'est une personne née
climato-sceptiques hier sur notre
plateau avait bernard debré personne
souligne simplement qu'on veut aborder
le problème le problème
les extraits qu'on voulait 6 ou plus
original est ce qu'on a les extraits
tellement gros qu'on je suis absolument
désaccord avec jimmy mohamed est ce que
vous dites est grave vous parlez de
guet-apens guet-apens c'est une
intention donc de blesser quelqu'un ou
de la ridiculiser moi je connais pascal
praud
on lui reproche la ce qui fait le sel de
son émission c'est un pain présentateur
classique c'est un présentateur qui
éditorialise il donne son point de vue
sur tout parfois un point de vue
conservateur qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas mais c'est son point de vue et là
c'est un débat face à face la personne
entre guillemets mise en cause à tout à
fait la latitude de répondre si elle est
mauvaise c'est sa faute elle peut
répondre elle est là elle est en dedans
mais elle est un peu seul contre tous à
l'histoire vous êtes bon et que vous
êtes seul c'est un faux débat
c'est pas ça qui me faudra attendre à ce
qu elle vraiment ce qui me choque
uniquement c'est le procès c'est ça la
cje le procès en sorcellerie
c'est à dire de dire monsieur vous êtes
misogyne monsieur vous êtes sexiste
monsieur vous êtes climato sceptiques
non c'est ça que je trouve que c'est de
ça que je veux qu'on parle aujourd'hui
c'est à dater quand c'est mine de rien
c'est vrai que la séquence la chauffer
mais vous avez vu les proportions que ça
a pris moi c'est surtout de ça je
voudrais qu'on parle c'est ça qui est
quand même incroyable
mine de rien après pascal est ce que
vous l'avez eu cette personne ce que
vous lui avez reparlé même un ensuite je
me conduis moi j'ai aucun souci pour
renouer le le contacta je veux dire
quand même quelque chose ce cri un but
ou ceux là dedans le but c'est qu'elle a
été et c'est de bonne guerre
elle s'est servie faut rassurer les en
campagne électorale
elle a fait un buzz si j'ai envie de
dire que j'étais seront meilleurs à
casser sa maladresse que de mauvais un
petit cachet la place publique parce que
effectivement on a beaucoup parlé de
place publique mais vraiment ce que je
trouve pas honnête je le répète on peut
dire pascal de temps en temps tu vas
trop loin
pascal tu as des excès pascal jazzy mais
tu peux pas dire à quelqu'un des choses
qui n'a pas dit par exemple quand on
prend le second degré pour du premier
quand je m'amuse en disant oh attention
et là le réchauffement climatique il a
fait -3 ce matin ses 16 ans formant
diatribe négationnistes sur le
réchauffement climatique alors les
politiques en mal de buzz et qui cherche
un restaurant mais vous rendez compte
que vous pouvez dire bonne plaisanterie
nul ce mauvais on rit pas de ça pourquoi
pas mais martine aubry maire de lille
mais c'est
a tribe négationnistes sur le
réchauffement climatique proposé est ce
que vous voulez je vous dois les révéla
il m'a pris je voudrais poser de la
mecque est sur place on touche du doigt
effectivement quelque chose qui est que
maintenant tout le monde parle parce que
tout le monde a envie de s'exprimer
parce qu'il ya un lieu qui s'appelle
twitter et autres et on parle sans avoir
vu alors on voit des montages on voit
l'homme qui a vu l'homme qui a vu
l'homme et et à partir de ça on se fait
une opinion une opinion qui en règle
générale est négatif parce qu'il s'agit
d' exister sur ces réseaux sociaux donc
mais ça c'est la règle du jeu à la
limite des réseaux sociaux
là où ça pose problème c'est
effectivement quand des gens qui ont des
responsabilités et notamment des
politiques viennent rajouter là-dessus
sans avoir vu l'ensemble l'entièreté de
l'émission et viennent se baser l'action
de dix ans soit effectivement je vais
m'en servir à des fins électorales soit
je vais m'en servir parce que je suis un
peu moins sous les feux de l'actualité
et je vais à nouveau me remette de sur
les feux de la rampe à bon compte et à
peu de frais voilà c'est là où il ya un
souci et ça veut dire que là à ce moment
là à la limite que le pékin moyen ait
envie de déverser y déverser c'est la
règle du jeu mais que des gens depuis
c'est alors c'est un niveau de violence
absolument ahurissant toujours mais à
oui mais enfin moi je suis pas ce qu'est
ce que ça vous a touché ce que vous avez
tué parce que vous en avez vu mais n'ont
rien vu ni ni dans votre iphone il est
souvent attaqué mais ce que là c'est là
le les touches et faty c'est pas
possible
vous avez du club de toulon qu'est ce
que vous avez pu lire comme exemple
balade de trucs vraiment qui vous a
vraiment blessé je dire sur sûr tu es
misogyne et sexiste c'est bon mais ça c
est des insultes je pas les répéter là
mais qui effectivement quand tu lis ça
que les anciennes cuisines
tu te dis il ya une volonté
effectivement de lire mais je ne répète
faut pas oublier le but c'est aussi des
militants en l'occurrence et des
militants politiques par exemple ceux
qui ont fait les vidéos il y en a un
c'est quelqu'un de clairement ancré à
gauche mais il se trouve que place
publique est un mouvement également
ancré à gauche et il ya une poursuite
politique forcément ça à la limite c'est
de se dire ces deux c'est de bonne
guerre
ce qui surprend effectivement c'est le
niveau de violence et de haine mais bon
c'est jean michel mariaggi michalak au
recteur zych hauteur que pascal praud
était sortie de son rôle
14e temps ce qui fait le sel succès
d'émissions c'est justement le parler
vrai du temps il le fait que pascal
praud titi autant c'est les habite et
que les chroniqueurs et que du coup ses
attaques ces petites j'attaque son
humour et son intelligence dans les
débats fait que le débat on arrive
finalement à se parler et qui y vivent
il arrive des choses la semaine et si on
peut plus dire à quelqu'un t'es dingue
c'est pas une insulte deux ans non lui
tombait donc à la télé dit non tu les
politiques on parle de climat
mais ça ne peut pas répondre à quelqu'un
arguments factuels tué dingue non je
suis désolé que je veux c'est la suite
de vos photos ça s'est passé à la
télévision fait l'invité que la barre la
cgt d'abord ce que pascal pascal vine
aubry évidemment elle est intelligente
et tous les gens de ma taxe soit et j'ai
donc ils savent très bien mais quand aux
fins de prendre le second degré au
niveau du premier degré bien sûr parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'équivoque
quand on feint de le prendre et de le
mettre dans la bouche comme si c'était
du premier degré la discuter ensemble
là tu es sûr de l'âme en fait de la
malhonnêteté moi je sais très bien que
martine aubry elle est intelligente elle
a bien décoder 2 elle a vu l'émission
pas mais effectivement galatée danse à
un combat politique
pascal est ce que tu as un regret sur
cette séquence ou pas du tout oui parce
que moi j'ai un regret parce que euh
comment dire comme ça part mal je dois
recentrer le débat
je ne trouve pas très bon pour tout dire
pour le recentrer et pour apaiser ou
calmer les choses et puis repartir sur
le fond du débat
donc là je peux me faire le reproche moi
je pense que pour faire des émissions de
télé faut être deux ou fait 3 ou phu cat
ou 5 mais faut être ensemble faut jouer
ensemble et manifestement disons le
chérir et on le voit après on a
l'impression d'être un poil piégée à
dire qu'après quelqu'un qui vient sur le
plateau et puis qui se servent d'une
certaine manière de cet incident pour
exister médiatiquement
pourquoi donc effectivement faut
toujours mieux s'en sortir avec de
l'humour avec de l'année gerba et faute
de trouver la bonne répartie
c'est toujours plus plus efficace
lorsque voilà on trouve le bon ton pour
apaiser voilà 6 g
au lieu si je lui ai dit que tu es bon
tu pensais que ça allait faire une
polémique comme ça ou pas du tout moi je
pense mais quand on sort du plateau il
ya il n'y a quasiment pas de tweet c'est
ça ouais et moi elle reste avec moi on
est ensemble je la raccompagne à quand
on sort de la première mi temps on est
ensemble on parle du bon coin d'ailleurs
vous pouvez voir tous les extraits après
je reviens pas s'apaiser
là pour le coup j'ai retrouvé le ton
qu'il faut dans l'émission par rapport à
la première mi temps qui était un peu
plus les troupes houleuse
sans donner il n'y a pas de souci et
c'est quand vous sortez le montage le
lendemain ça et j'ai vu des journalistes
c'est ça je vais pas les citer je les ai
appelés jeudi veux tu as vu dinh ont
marqué ce cas aujourd'hui sa tournée
pourquoi ça a tourné je remercie
d'ailleurs libération a fait un chèque
news wim wenders très très bel article
formidable formidable donc à la retraite
arrive à rétablir et après les gens
seront ok cela en revanche les autres
ont une idée ils pourront dire pascal
mais comment dire moi avec mes invités
parfois ça m'arrive de l'est entre
guillemets les malmener c'est donc il y
avait un essai chez qui s'appelait
patrick bloche il était sorti de
l'émission donc mais si on me dit vous
parler à une femme comme vous parlez pas
un homme
questionné je réponde à ça ça c'est tu
peux pas dire ça un animateur moi je
parle un homme ou une femme me
semble-t-il de la même manière en pleurs
et que vous vous regardez souvent vos
invités vous désirez on l'a montré plein
de fois ici regardez claire coudray ou
de pascal province et on apprend
beaucoup plus ouvert mais c'est ce qui
fait j'ai quitté les champs de vision si
vous avez quelque chose à dire à claire
nouvian de ce soir vous lui diriez quoi
écouter d'abord que je lui souhaite
vraiment dû beaucoup de réussite en
politique
ouais bien évidemment puisque lé je
crois 78e sur 79 dans la liste place
publique
donc elle et je prends meeting ces
prochains jours vous les gars le vol un
peu comme moi j'en veux en général j'en
veux à personne si si j'en veut
généralement à quelqu'un c'est à moi
parce que c'est une émission n'a pas
marché c'est ça j'en suis comme vous
maintenant c'est moi le responsable
j'en veux à personne parce que je ne
suis pas dupe voilà je sais très bien
j'ai compris comment ça marche comment
ça fonctionne et ça